Film Courage: So I know you’ve produced
numerous movies, you’ve worked for other
people but you’ve wanted to direct for a
very long time and I was wondering what that
journey was like?
And now to finally be able to direct three
movies (and more are on the horizon it sounds
like), as well?
Passionflix, Co-Founder Tosca Musk: Well,
I did two movies prior to Passionflix.
I directed two movies prior to Passionflix,
three movies actually.
I started out as an actor and then went into
directing and then after directing my first
feature I realized it’s like really, really
hard to actually get it out and do things
and then I went into producing and I produced
for the next 10 years.
It was after I had my kids that I realized
I wanted to do something that’s more creatively
fulfilling for me.
And I went and met with an executive producer
who I produced a couple of movies for before
and she is an awesome woman.
She works at Lifetime now (her name is Sharon
Bodis).
And she said “What do you want to do?”
And I said “I want to direct.”
And she goes “Hmmm…I’ll let you direct.
I have a movie now.
Do you want to direct it?”
And I went “Yeah, sure!”
And she said “Okay.”
And within a month I was on prep with that
movie and directing.
It was called YOU CAST A SPELL ON ME and that’s
the one the Joany saw.
So having that lunch with her basically changed
my life and brought us to Passionflix because
she said I could direct that movie, Joany
saw it, she loved it, Joany contacted me and
now we have Passionflix.
That’s basically it.
That’s the short story.
I got to make two movies for Sharon.
I made that one and then the following year
they hired me to make a CINDERELLA CHRISTMAS,
which was a Christmas story and also a love
story for ION as well.
Great experience, that’s where I met Emma
Rigby and as soon as we made Passionflix,
I asked Emma Rigby to be my first female lead
of Passionflix for HOLLYWOOD DIRT.
So it all just sort of worked together.
I was very fortunate.
Of course it was 15 years of slogging to get
to that point.
But I was very fortunate to be given that
opportunity by a great supporter of women.
Film Courage: So to know that someone believed
in you that quickly, where you were probably
just coming down the line and [possibly] this
was something (probably you weren’t expecting
it so fast), what was that first day on set
like?
Terrifying?
Empowering?
Both?
Tosca Musk: It was exciting, actually.
I definitely felt that I was in my own and
that I owned it for sure.
It was a very positive experience.
That entire movie was wonderful.
Again the two lead actors that I worked with
(Ryan McPartlin and Nikki Deloach) had great
chemistry.
We had great chemistry together.
And so we still are in contact and we still
want to make another movie another.
And so it was a really positive experience.
I knew exactly what I wanted as a filmmaker.
I had a great DP with me and he was very knowledgeable
(a lot of experience).
Oh!
Actually on that one I didn’t [have him]
but I had a great DP.
She was new to the field in that particular
one but she was so supportive.
So I had the DP that I had a lot of experience
on my next movie CINDERELLA CHRISTMAS.
So it was a positive experience, it was just
fun.
And I think once you’re doing something
that you are passionate about and that you
really, truly believe you should be doing,
you do a great job, you excel in that.
And that’s why to me it’s not considered
work, it’s considered play.
So I can do it forever, which is great, I
have a great time.
Film Courage: So going back to that first
experience [as a director], it was also the
chemistry and the environment.
It all seemed to kind of work?
Tosca Musk: Yeah, the chemistry and the environment,
I mean I think at the end of the day (and
I’ve been fortunate to have been told this
by a lot of my crew members) is that the environment
is created by the director.
So the director, the mood on set is going
to be based on how the director is feeling
that day.
And if I was throwing tantrums and yelling
at everybody, probably it wouldn’t have
been a great set to work on.
But I arrived and we were laughing and joking
and having a fun time from the second we started
and so everybody was laughing and joking and
having a great time and that really helped.
My producer Jina (who is the producer on all
the movies, as well) she and I have a No A**hole
Policy on the set.
We actually give people a warning so when
we hire them we say “Hi, listen the only
drama that happens on set is going to be on
screen.
So if you’re going to be dramatic in anyway
and cause problems, you are welcome to leave.
You don’t have to stay.
Nobody is making you work here.
If you don’t like it, you are absolutely
welcome to leave.
But if you do like it, we’d love for you
to stay and let’s have a great time.
We are going to make a movie and it’s not
rocket science, it’s not brain surgery and
people’s lives are not on the line here.
So let’s just have fun creating something.”
And so that goes over really well with a lot
of crew members.
And there have been a few times that we’ve
had crew members that have been…(and actors)
people who have not been nice.
And so we kindly invite them to leave…rarely.
Film Courage: So having that sense of humor…yeah…I
would hope so…it happens…it definitely
does.
Sometimes people clash, whatever.
I think also having a sense of humor [helps].
Sometimes I don’t always see that in people
and even if it’s just going to the grocery
story and it’s rare…maybe it’s just
because Los Angeles is so crowded and everybody
is thinking of being somewhere else, doing
something else.
But maybe having that sense of humor and people
think “Okay, I can relax a little bit.”
Tosca Musk: Yeah, I’ve very funny on set
apparently!
I love laughter.
Romantic comedies are my strength so that
is what I love to make the most.
HOLLYWOOD DIRT was definitely a great one
for me, it’s an empowering woman but it’s
a comedy and it’s a romance.
And then MATCHMAKERS PLAYBOOK, it’s a romance
and a comedy.
What was actually hard for me was AFTERBURN/AFTERSHOCK
because it’s a drama.
So I had to try and figure out how to make
a drama and still keep it light and funny
on set because there are so many dramatic
scenes in that movie.
But if you see the behind-the-scenes, as soon
as I call cut everyone is laughing and having
a great time.
I whistle a lot so people…I whistle and
I sing on set, a lot!
Which is somewhat embarrassing because I don’t
realize that I’m doing it until the boom
operator or the sound mixer will come up and
just start recording it and then they’ll
play it back and I’ll be like “Oh…wow!
Yes that’s me whistling on set.”
But it keeps it…there’s a levity then
to set, it just keeps everything light and
fun and I think that’s important.
But romantic comedy is definitely my strength,
I say.
Although I did like making AFTERBURN/AFTERSHOCK.